pipeau when you're in the street depuis
pour le past and call you mr mcnee au mr
steed
comment vous appelle-t-il les gens quand
vous passez pas bien ils sourient ils
sont contents de me voir
peu importe le nom qu'ils me donnent à
travers le monde on m'a salué comme ça
depuis 30 ans pendant ces 30 dernières
années et cela fait que j'ai beaucoup
d'amis à travers le manger ni mais il
dit tant pis est ce que vous aimez le
chant peinture like jumping nos noms du
champagne very special boat au jumping
very special et c'est john steed
spéciaux pour moi il il faut pas boire
si le gères tu crois que c'est une très
bonne idée de vous en tenez quand même
la glace comme baby pensez bien voilà
est-ce que tu as linda